هذه صور مباشره نتابعها واياكم مشاهدينا
الكرام على شاشه العربيه لربما عمليه
انقاذ احد
من يعني بقوا تحت الركام وتحت المباني
المهدمه والمباني ايضا التي
انهارت بسبب زلزال المدمر في تركيا في
مدينه البستان تحديدا فرق الانقاذ
والطوارئ وكذلك ايضا المسعفين فرق ربما
ايضا تركيا ودوليه ايضا تتابع حاله
يعني من تم اخراجه من تحت الانقاذ في هذه
الصوره يعني لا نعلم ان كان حيا ام قضى
تحت الانقاض نحن نتحدث اليوم عن سته ايام
بعد هذه الفاجعه
المدمره هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا هذه الصور ننقلها لكم من البستان
في تركيا هناك تجمع اذا والتفاف حول يعني
احد من تم اخراجهم من تحت انقاب الركام
عمليه انقاذ ربما انها نجحت يعني في ان
يتم اخراج هذا الشخص
حيا وبصحه وعافيه سنتابع كنا تابعنا
واياكم اليوم عائشه التي خرجت نعم الان
نتابع هذه الصور لاخراج الدفاع المدني فرق
الانقاذ ايضا لاحد من كانوا عالقين تحت
الركام وتحت احد المباني
المنهاره في مدينه البستان يبدو فعلا ان
فرق الانقاذ قد اخرجت يعني هذا الشخص الذي
كان تحت الركام وايضا بقى لمده اكثر من
1525 ساعه تحت الانقاض والركام يعني نتمنى
انه خرج بصحه
بانه ايضا لم يقضي تحت هذه الامطار ويبدو
انه بصحه وعافيه